joining us now the carolina panthers
first round pick in 2015 linebacker shaq
thompson shaq welcome to the program how
are you buddy
i'm doing good man thanks for having me
how about yourselves
hey we're doing great we're doing great
great to see you great to have you on
the program and you know 2015 that was
the year the carolina panthers made it
to the super bowl and here we are super
bowl week what's the one thing that
stands out to you when you reflect on
super bowl 50 and that entire experience
that entire season getting to the super
bowl and playing in it uh just the
commodity and the culture of the guys um
and just playing each and every week you
never know if you're gonna win or lose
and just come in here focus on one week
at a time then get into the big stage
you see all
the all the just like the cool stuff
they got the super bowl all the media
all the events all the
just like an experience so that's what i
miss and hopefully we'll get back there
soon
yeah definitely man i mean it looks like
you guys are building something there
certainly now 2015 you're the rookie
you're learning luke lee's there
now this year it was a new experience
like for you i think at least what what
was life like is a linebacker without
luke keackley next to you and you kind
of the qb of the defense
um it was a little different because uh
after that year i was looking forward to
playing with luke uh this year and then
found out that he retired so it's just
like boom oh everything's on you now so
but i was very i was taught very well
from luke from thomas on how to become a
leader on and off the field and how
that role is just
stays in the standard of the linebacker
room and so i was prepared for that and
they got me prepared for it
you know i remember that luke kickley
retirement shack it was a lightning bolt
for all of us did you have any idea it
was coming
nah i had no idea and the funny thing
was i was on a plane and luke was like
yo i need i'ma call you i was like man
i'm on a flight then
i go by internet and i've seen it luke
keegan retire and i was like dang i just
brought tears to my eyes on the plane
because i was like i said i was looking
forward to him and uh
and i was ready to go
you you a lot of adjustments i mean you
had ron rivera
now you get a guy that comes out of
college and matt rule just talk about
him and kind of like his stamp that he's
put on the organization
uh he came in and put a great mark on us
we talked about the process and and the
stuff that we want to build and the
culture that we want to build here and
he's done a great job just improving
myself uh event and all the young guys
that just get getting better and
believing the process
of what this new culture is around here
and um
and i'm all i'm all for it
it was funny that first draft with matt
rule every single selection was a
defensive player what was your reaction
when you saw that
uh that's above my pay grade but uh they
knew what they were doing um
they know the ins and outs of the stuff
uh they know we needed help on defense
and you know what they went out and went
to go get his help i know those guys
that you're showing right now they all
contributed and they all gotten better
each and every week
well yeah you know the best part about
that hang on the best part about that
you look at that graphic not a single lb
yes every other level except yours
well you could consider chin as a lb lb
safety yeah you put him down hybrid
right yeah he's similar to you really in
a lot of ways you were that guy coming
out and in a lot of ways like a safety
linebacker hybrid i want to ask you
because i mean it's super bowl 55 it's
buck's chiefs and damn you played
against both of them so i'd like to know
you know give me your you know your two
cents on the bucks and the chiefs and
what really stood out to you playing
against them
uh just playing against tom brady first
of all and i already knew playing
against the bucks the bucks were a good
team they just needed that one missing
piece and and they got it and you see
what they're doing now with it but i
love playing against them the great
competition and just playing against the
chief you hear about patrick mahomes and
man he's the best and all this stuff and
playing against them you're like man
this dude is good he has good players
around him and um but that's a game i
still wish we we would have had
the the uh the
feeling about the panthers going into
the season was it's a rebuilding year
record's not going to be great and you
guys fought you
you you guys
played well week in and week out where
did that fire come from where did that
passion come from to not just say this
is kind of a scholarship year for
everyone but we're going to go out there
and we're gonna do our our best and
we're gonna we're gonna try to surprise
some people
it came from the guys but it also came
from the coaching staff um that's what
it they instilled in us from day one
like we're gonna fight we're gonna play
hard knows football we're gonna go from
first quarter to fourth quarter we're
going to be the most physical team in
the nfl and and that's what we believed
in and that's what we could see you
could see the potential
and what we have you can see
the players and what we have it's not
like we have big names but we have guys
that will go out there and play 60
minutes of football yeah actually that i
wanted to go there because that that is
i think the impre you got a lot of like
physically freaky guys on your team that
are not household names yet you derek
brown you talked about jeremy chin
and dj moore curtis samuel like
mccaffrey i that i i want you to answer
that like who is the the freakiest
athlete on the team to shaq thompson you
can't name yourself either but give us
that guy you think doesn't get enough
credit as far as you know the mainstream
media
uh i think the whole team honestly uh
there's a lot of guys out there who do
that who does their assignment and does
their job but don't get enough
recognition because somebody might have
10 tackles or something like that or
somebody might have
100 yards but it's really like the
offensive lineman who held the dn all
pro dn from not getting a sack or or
something like that so i think a lot of
guys are special in all different ways
but the 10.1 guy um
i would say
last year curtis samuel was one of those
guys who really just stood out to
everybody but he didn't he didn't get
enough recognition in my eyes
ron rivera had been your coach for all
of your career until this past year did
you keep in in much touch with him did
you follow everything he went through he
had a ton of adversity obviously
overcame cancer uh any communication
with him any thoughts on him now that
it's been a year since he's been gone
um i just wished him luck um after they
let him go um then once i found out he
had cancer i kind of just told him there
and i was like keep your head up coach
keep fighting um
but other than that not really um my
coach is coach rule and i play for the
panthers so that's that's what my head
in mind is that
walter payton nfl man of the year the
team's representative one of the
finalists for the prize what does that
mean to you personally
uh it means a lot because it's something
that i don't do for the limelight it's
something that i don't do for media or
something like that something i do for
my heart and um
if it wasn't no cameras and nothing like
that i would love it um but it comes
with the tutorial of what i do i love
getting back giving back to the
community um it's something that my mom
taught us to just growing up uh before
she passed away last year just give back
open up your home open up your arms and
let people come in because you know you
don't know whose life you may change
shaq i'm sorry to hear about your mom uh
that's always a very very difficult
thing to go through and we wish you the
best moving forward i'm sure she'd be
extremely proud of where you are right
now especially as a walter payton nfl
man of the year finalist and uh we wish
you the best we look forward to talking
to you down the road pal
appreciate that man you guys have a good
one you too you the man shaq
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports